Oh Olaf should get to URI we were so
excited to see your journey into the
unknown alongside on a Kristoff Olaf and
Sven and your journey to self-discovery
didn't disappoint we're so happy for you
Elsa you knew that awakening the spirits
of the forest would be a risk but you
took it anyway because deep down you
know it was what you were supposed to do
into the unknown is one of our favourite
songs from frozen - it gave us insight
on how you were feeling and who you
wanted to be we're about to dissect the
lyrics of into the unknown
this song has a hidden meaning that's
just too good to miss so don't go
anywhere let's jump right in the intro
in frozen Elsa finally comes out of her
shell when she chooses to let it go but
by the time frozen 2 comes around it's
clear that Elsa still has a knack for
bottling things up when she first hears
a voice calling to her while playing
charades she keeps it to herself
but when the voice weight salsa up in
the middle of the night she goes looking
for it in the intro portion of into the
unknown we hear the same voice calling
out to Elsa how's Elsa seemed weird to
you she
seems like Elsa and that's when things
get interesting the first first in the
first purse Elsa sings about hearing a
strange voice calling to her but not
wanting to go to it she knows that she
shouldn't entertain it but she can't
help herself she doesn't want to go
looking for trouble and as Queen she
knows she has more important things to
do than listen to the voice in her head
but things just aren't that simple our
we've got new people please make sure
they stay out of the kingdom until we
return
of course the second verse hearing a
voice that no one else hears is a call
for concern but instead of seeking help
Elsa tries to convince herself that the
voice doesn't exist Elsa knows what
she's risking by going after the voice
but while she wishes it was just a
ringing in her ear it isn't Elsa sings
about already being spoken for she's got
a sister and Friends to look after and
she's queen who can't go off into the
unknown
just like that Elsa also mentions that
she's already had her great adventure
and that she doesn't want to uproot her
life by following the voice I just
wanted to be perfect sound the chorus
the chorus is a mix of the secret sirens
calls and Elsa sings about following it
into the unknown these two melodies come
together beautifully and it becomes
clear that Elsa's first adventure wasn't
enough for her she wants more for
herself she wants to go north
I won't let anything happen to the third
verse I also always had trust issues
which is why she prefers to work alone
her stuff can I borrow your wagon and
spend mm-hmm I'm not very comfortable
with the idea of things you are not
going along in the third verse she
questions the voice afraid that it could
be distracting her so she makes a big
mistake like waking up the spirits of
the forest it's in this first that Elsa
finally admits that she feels connected
to the voice in her mind the voice
belongs to someone just like her someone
who isn't where they're supposed to be
this revelation just goes to show how
much Elsa has been suffering since she
became the queen of arendelle as the
first born Elsa is destined to rule but
secretly she wants nothing more than to
go off on her own the pre-chorus the
pre-chorus tells us what most of us
already knew Elsa is having a hard time
adjusting to normal life she reveals
that her powers are growing stronger and
that unlike before when she said that
she didn't want to risk what she had
part of her wants to put everything on
the line for the truth the bridge by the
time else it gets to the bridge of the
song it's painfully clear that she's
going to do something drastic and she
wants to find out more about the person
calling out to her she feels connected
to the voice in a very familiar and
scary way at the beginning of the song
she wanted the voice to leave her alone
but now she wants it to show her where
she comes from ona know I have my powers
to protect me you don't the outro when
the voice starts to slip away
Elsa sort of panics she wants to know
where it's going and begs for it not to
leave her alone
at this point Elsa is ready to take the
plunge so she awakens the spirits of the
forest in hopes that they'll guide her
away from arendelle and into the unknown
it's here that it becomes clear that
Elsa never really intended on going back
to arendelle to live a normal life she
knew then that it wasn't her destiny
spirit the things we post new and
exciting videos about all of your
favorite movies
and celebrities hit that subscribe
button and turn on those post
notifications to be notified whenever we
upload a new video this way you can be
the first to leave a comment if you're
watching on your mobile go on YouTube
settings and turn on notifications and
that's a wrap on the lyric breakdown of
into the unknown which frozen to song is
your all-time favorite sound off in the
comments thanks for watching the things
before you go don't forget to give this
video a big thumbs up we'll catch you
later
[Music]